so when you did the the ending of the
movie you have Idris
um talking to Chris about
um and talking about his boss when you
put something like that in how much are
you and Joe do you already know who that
character is or how much is it sort of
just fun to put out something and be
like we'll figure it out later if we get
to do extraction three uh I think it's a
we know who the character wants to be
I don't think we we don't know yet know
who that actor is who's going to portray
that character if that makes sense so
you know by saying something like that
what you're doing is you know you just
had two pretty wild movies with Tyler
Rick what is going to be upping the ante
what are the stakes how are they
elevated and by just dropping a single
line like you know he's a gnarly you
know mother effort you're like okay one
line then says some this is someone who
might be in the same league as Tyler
rake now I'm intrigued and so as a
character we know who this person is
going to have to be
who is going to portray that I think
that's the beauty of that line it's like
now that single line could go out and
attract a lot of cool amazing actors to
play that you know wild character so
it's a little bit of a little bit of
both but I think we wanted to leave it
open and yet um capture the essence of
what was needed for the next film for
Tyler rake how much did you and Joe
debate where and how to end the movie
you know the ending actually was
gonna happen pretty early and it didn't
it didn't change a lot like that
ironically like I mean I don't think our
irony is not the right to um you know
feeling there but incidentally it didn't
change that much A lot of things
throughout the movie changed with the
ending uh once we had an idea that and
this is spoilers right we can talk about
things once once adrius was on board and
we knew that you know we wanted uh his
character to kind of top it off there at
the end as like a little it was kind of
like a a version of a post-credits
marble scene right like you wanted to be
like have him there at the end again so
you could people could start to
speculate and go oh shoot they're gonna
be in a movie together after this so
once we had that and it was working
we're like nah that's we're good we
don't there's no reason to mess with
that did you guys debate putting in like
an after the credits scene or was it
sort of like never on the table no I
wasn't really on the table just because
you know I mean it's hard to you're not
really going to out Marvel so we were
like let's let's save that for the let's
let this movie Stand Alone as what it is
which is a sequel that honors the first
movie and hopefully ties up Tyler Rick's
um you know current dramatic
um you know dilemma and allow him to go
off to the next one free and clear and
let's just see how people respond and
then develop what that is the other
thing I wanted to know is how did you
decide who was going to live and die in
the movie
um and was it ever going to be possible
other things other choices uh it was I
mean we we went back and forth I mean
there's only you know so many characters
that would
um affect Tyler in the way that you need
him to be affected it's because you need
that moment there where we're for the
for the team or you lose something
valuable like you you you take a risk
you're you're making this big move to
take this family away from these super
powerful people you have to lose
something at least to raise the stakes
for the third act that's what was my
feeling
and so yeah we played with it some some
different characters but ended up with
um you know
yes being the the one to choose because
we thought that
that helped
motivate like two beloved characters
which was Tyler Rick and Nick Khan so
and we wanted to you know because people
huge fans of Nick like she she has
garnered such a following from the from
these movies that we wanted to make sure
that you know she was serviced as well
meaning like that her character had some
really meaty stuff to hold on to
um so we figured we landed with Yaz
because
it did two for the price of one
basically we have the guilt that rake
feels of like bringing them into this
and like his friend close friend and
brother basically
and then the actual Blood Brother of
Nick dies and so that she's conflicted
like what you know what is she doing
here and and interestingly and here's a
fun like kind of spoiler alert there's
we did this scene this is a scene that
was in and out and it was out and it was
in
where Nick is talking she brings in the
you know the
um strudels to the the mom and kid who
were in the bed in Vienna and they have
a talk about second chances that was a
scene that was kind of in it was out uh
but we left it in because one it means
multiple meanings she's talking yes
about the kid but she's also talking
about rake because she's also talking
about you know the Sun
and she throwed me through a line in
there when she talks and she's kind of
empathizing with the mom and saying I
know what it feels like I've been there
and we're like we're trying to like it's
subtle it's an it's a you know it's a
Easter egg but that's kind of hinting
towards
her and yaz's own spin-off movie so
we're gonna like get to follow them and
again this is not this is a spoiler
don't put this out there this is an
aggler thing they should be the ones to
to release that but we put that line in
there to to pique interest for people
about her backstory like whoa like what
what do you know about like how do you
know how she feels like were you a
mother did you like what what so we
tried to just put that in there and that
scene went back and forth and back and
forth but the Intrigue that it brought
to the story caused it to remain yeah
the biggest thing I found with agbo is
that they have so many things that they
could work on in terms of sequels
prequels spin-offs like the list goes on
and on and there's just only so many
hours in the day I know right it's like
they have such a a mind for Universe
building I think it's like part of it I
think is just innate in them and I think
the other part is that you know time at
Marvel just seeing like connecting dots
like that and they just you're right
it's a plethora of ideas and it could go
so many ways I mean they could they
could stock Netflix you know the pages
for for days like they'd be they could
be the sole provider for probably years
of content
also people love action movies it's not
like this is gonna go away I mean action
you know people love action movies and
when they're well done that is you know
when they're above you know we've all
seen action that is it's you know it's
fine but you know extraction raises the
level you know in terms of anyway